Lauren I'll come your way first it's the
new addition to the Ensemble what is one
thing about Liv's performance from
season one that you deliberately wanted
to uphold but then also what's something
that you wanted to do different to show
how that has evolved over the years well
I just really loved Liv's performance
that
was so good that they decided to keep
the character around and and now I have
a gig so I'm grateful for that
um
I guess that I mean I don't know I'm so
amazed by the the combination of
extremely vulnerable and extremely tough
extremely capable
you know the characters a Survivor from
the first scene you see her she is
waking her drunk mother to before she
goes off to the
to the soccer
trip
um
and then I you know and the character is
so like the performance was so beautiful
and open and
um
alive and
um and even in the face of so so many
harrowing staring death in the face
experiences and um
I think when we find
van grown up that the characters kind of
hardened and calcified and
um dimmed and and um
seemingly okay but but kind of you know
functioning clearly sort of but not not
um
I don't know like the the light is is
turned way down
I don't know that's what I was going for
I don't know what you mean um just
curious what would your van say is the
fave is her favorite movie of all time
bound
it isn't it's not a show there's a
reference in the show I believe that or
um Christina for you last time we spoke
you were telling me a little bit about
how over the course of season one you
grew to trust the show Runners and you
were looking forward to that giving you
the ability to really go big with
Misty's uh childlike vulnerability and
also her twistedness so what is
something you're able to do in season
two that you know you can credit to that
established trust from season one I mean
I trusted them from the beginning I
think the second I read the pilot and
spoke to them and they were you know
they're so talented and the writing was
so good and everything I trusted them
from season one uh from episode one
um and uh it has been so fun and in in
season two
um you know Misty is sort of put into
somewhat more relatable circumstances so
she has to then exhibit a little bit
more normal emotions and reactions but
she's of course Misty so it was fun to
get to play with uh how immature she is
and emotionally stunted and she is in
all those situations it's a great effect
yet again Melanie for you just to set
the scene for us for Shawna at the very
beginning what do you think is like the
number one thing guiding her in terms of
how she's responding to having killed
Adam is it the focus on covering it up
remorse anything in particular that's
kind of starting her and just and
justifying the particular decision she
makes in episode one I think that she's
been Guided by pure panic
and
the knowledge that she's just made a
series of bad decisions and she probably
shouldn't make any more but she just
can't seem to stop
um you know there's a lot going on in
episode one when you know Misty is like
well you got rid of this and this and
this and she is hanging on to those
things out of remorse she's hanging on
to those things because it's a person
she to care about and she's not yet
processed the fact that she actually
killed someone who really liked her and
what does that mean like she's she's an
interesting one